hi I'm Evan Carmichael welcome to
another edition of ask Evan in today's
episode I'm going to answer question
from one of my newsletter readers vixen
who wrote in frustrated about trying to
start a new business vixen has a lot of
pressures to bring in money for the
family and also has a visual handicap
and it's finding the challenging to get
this new business off the ground and one
of my advice on what type of businesses
start and how to get it going so vixen
thanks for the question hopefully can
give me some advice to help you out the
first thing and most important thing at
least in my mind to be a successful
entrepreneur is you have to follow your
passion you gotta do something you love
something if you can really add a lot of
value to other people's lives so you
know something think about what you do
every day that helps people and see this
awake and turn that into a business or
you might take it another way think
about something that you solve for
yourself a big frustration of your own
that you solve and you know maybe you
could have other people pay you to do
that same thing for them solve
frustrations for them so I try to start
around there you don't necessarily need
to start full time when you can start
this on a part-time basis get to know
you know the businesses that you're
interested in you still make money while
you're learning about the world of
entrepreneurship so you don't understand
how they just jump right in you can
still make money make your mistakes you
don't work for somebody else and then
see if it's also for you before you go
launch your own business and then the
last bit would be just try launching a
service and product businesses are
really expensive usually require a lot
of inventory a lot of capital you're
going and if you make a mistake you've
got all this stuff hanging around where
service allows you to get paid more
quickly you know faster right up front
you get money and it ties you to your
customers you can really build around
them and what their pains are you get to
know your customers a little better and
you can bring in a significant and
ongoing steady stream of cash which then
you can use to launch your product
business afterwards on an ongoing basis
service business is a heart of the scale
but they're easy
start you can start with the service
business bringing the money and then
turn your attention towards creating a
product that might be a bigger business
in the end hopefully that helps if you
guys liked the video please give it a
thumbs up and I'd love to hear what you
have to think you can want to leave a
comment under the video and we'll see
you on the next episode
you